from a young age authority figures
pervade our lives
parents telling us to clean our rooms
professors assigning essays
would we be as inclined to follow these
directions if a robot was in charge hi
welcome to class
robots have already been tested in
positions of power such as the now robot
which has been used to teach students
but scientists haven't deeply explored
how bots and authority positions can
influence human decision making to test
this human robot interaction researchers
used pepper a roughly one meter tall
robot with a human-like face
they created two different study groups
those who are pepper's peers and those
who were under pepper's direction
the researchers gave pepper both formal
and real authority
formal authority comes from social roles
in specific contexts
the scientists established pepper as an
authority figure using several tactics
the robot was the only presence in the
room and used possessive language
we'll get started my name is pepper and
i'm glad you could join me
real authority is tied to control over
decision making such as financial
incentives
pepper administered tests under two
conditions a
i will reward you a dollar for a correct
guess and the reward will shrink by 25
cents for each floor your guest is off
and a punishment
i will punish you 25 cents for each
number you are off to a maximum of one
dollar
under the pure condition a human laid
out the instructions punishments and
rewards okay here we go
next participants completed challenging
memory tasks
after the participant's guess pepper
offered a suggestion the correct
response
i think i counted six
okay personally i counted seven police
stations
participants had to decide whether to
stick to their initial answer or take
pepper's advice
now what is the final guess you would
like to walk in
yeah i'll go with seven i'm not sure so
the researchers measured pepper's
persuasiveness by calculating how the
suggested guess influenced the final
answer
participants also completed a survey at
the end of the study where they rated
statements about pepper on a seven-point
scale
the researchers found that pepper was
more persuasive in a peer setting than
in an authority role which differs from
observations seen in human to human
interactions
participants were also more likely to
take the robot's suggestions when
rewards were offered i got to the same
location
this might be because participants
viewed pepper's advice as less risky
than their own
and as a well-suited task for a robot to
complete
these results could guide how people
design robots as more of a helper to
accomplish a task rather than a formal
authority figure the next time you run
into a robot it may have the art of
persuasion nailed down
[Music]